as many of you know the rounded apple
watch series 7 design caused a ton of
controversy last year because literally
everyone was expecting a new flat sided
redesign to happen which we had been
seeing all over the internet in terms of
renders and even leaked cad files but no
apple came out and released an even more
rounded series 7. so the big question
that was on everyone's mind was where
the heck did that boxy design come from
since what we got was the complete
opposite of course some people concluded
that apple set up a bunch of fake leaks
just to mess with and potentially trap
some of the leakers like john prosser
from front page tech who originally
shared the boxy design renders but new
information has just come out that
confirms that this isn't true at all and
before i get into that i want to share
my point of view on why all of this
happened my initial reaction was that
apple did plan on releasing the boxy
apple watch design but that something
went terribly wrong so they scrapped it
and went with a backup design which
ended up being the series 7 that we got
but then that doesn't make as much sense
as my second theory what if the boxy
design was actually meant to be the
explorer or rugged edition that mark
german leaked earlier in 2021
but then he ended up reporting that it
was delayed until 2022 and if you're
wondering how that boxy design could
ever be considered rugged well some
people would say that the new iphone 12
and 13 boxy designs make the phones a
lot more durable or rugged because the
display glass is now protected by the
boxy exterior shell which features a
small lip around the entire display
which is now also completely flat which
makes it even stronger and that's
exactly the design that was leaked for
the series 7. flat sides all around with
the display on top being completely flat
protected by a metal lip which in my
opinion makes it a whole lot more rugged
and now many months later john prosser
finally revealed a huge secret about
those boxy apple watch renders that he
kept hidden from all of us the entire
time and this is probably the biggest
piece of evidence for my second theory
actually being true and it would
essentially mean that we're finally
going to be getting the flat sided
redesign with the apple watch series 8
pro model and if you're wondering what i
mean by pro model i'll explain after i
get into john's secret mac rumors
recently created a new podcast where
they invited john prosser to join as a
guest and of course they hammered him on
the whole boxy design leak that never
came to light and within this podcast he
ended up revealing exactly what went
wrong apparently he actually received a
real image of a prototype flat sided
apple watch design in the new starlight
finish which is a huge piece of evidence
for these leaks not being faked by apple
and john even confirmed that after the
september event none of his sources
within apple were caught so this means
that apple didn't fabricate all this
stuff to intentionally weed out the
sources and it means that these design
leaks are actually true but going even
further he ended up revealing the
original renders from his sources that
he kept a secret from the very beginning
and to my shock those renders showed not
one but two apple watch designs and
according to john he initially thought
that the smaller watch on the left was
simply the regular series 6 that we
already had at the time with the new
boxy one on the right side which was
supposed to be the new boxy series 7
design but nope he was wrong after apple
revealed the more rounded true series 7
he looked back at the renders and
realized that the watch on the left was
actually a more rounded series 7 design
which ended up getting released and is
likely the intended design for the
regular series 8 model as well and then
the larger one on the right was most
likely meant to be a brand new extra
series 8 model which i personally
believe is the new rugged or explorer
edition which ended up getting delayed
until 2022 but the big question that
everyone on the mac rumors podcast had
was why the boxing one on the right was
so much bigger than the one on the left
because they all thought it made sense
for the new rugged edition to be a
smaller apple watch se model at the low
end but in my opinion it's actually the
opposite i believe the new boxy design
is meant to be marketed as a pro model
that's going to be more expensive than
the regular series 8 because apple will
be able to bring the average sales price
up and offer the highest end features on
this new pro model first and if you
don't believe me i also have some
overwhelming evidence from the very
reliable display analyst ross young who
said that we should expect three
different apple watch display sizes in
2022 and that perfectly matches up to
more recent leaks that say that we are
in fact getting three new apple watches
this year a new se a regular series 8
and a new rugged edition but the most
important detail that ross young gave us
was that the third display size is
actually gonna be bigger than the
current series seven yes bigger which
would explain the larger size in john's
renders so in my opinion it makes sense
for the new apple watch se to have a
display size of 40 to 44 millimeters
just like the series 6 and then the new
regular series 8 model to have an
identical display from the series 7
which is 41 to 45 millimeters and then
the new rugged series 8 pro model to
come with a 42 to 46 millimeter display
size perfectly matching up to what ross
young leaked and this theory also
matches up to most of the other leaks
out there including john prosser's leaks
and it also matches up to simple common
sense because if you think about it the
best way to get people to pay more money
for an apple watch is to call it the pro
model just like they've done with
literally the rest of their products
like the iphone pro the mac pro and the
ipad pro and to go along with the pro
title they've got to give it a redesign
that looks nothing like every apple
watch that they've ever made before to
of course differentiate it and make it
look special so people will know when
someone paid extra for the pro model and
finally having a pro model would also
allow apple to throw in the most
expensive new technology on that model
first before slowly bringing it down to
the rest of the apple watch lineup just
like they've been doing with the ipad
pro and the iphone pro and the cool
thing about all of this is that apple
can guarantee that this new pro model
will be more rugged because of the flat
display glass that is going to be
stronger which is hidden behind the
metal rim
and they can offer it in titanium only
which will make it more tough but the
key point i want to make is that making
the display glass completely flat will
actually save apple a ton of internal
space which will allow them to throw in
a larger battery which is something that
people would definitely pay extra for
and it would make it worthy of the pro
title but going even further the new
larger flat design is literally the only
way that apple will be able to add mac
safe support to the apple watch just
like they did to both the airpods 3 and
the airpods pro case and if you don't
believe me mark german who is incredibly
reliable has been talking about apple
adding magsafe support to the apple
watch for months now and this new larger
pro model is the only way it makes sense
for this to happen so if you take a step
back and look at all these leaks
together i think this theory is by far
the most logical and it basically checks
all of the boxes in terms of the reports
from various different sources and with
that said i think it's very likely that
we'll be seeing this new boxy redesign
revealed at apple's september event just
seven months from now and if you totally
disagree with me go ahead and let me
know down in the comment section below
but if you enjoyed this video click that
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next one
[Music]